bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le
tour ensemble de l'actualité politique
et parlementaire avec à mes côtés
michael à metz bonjour bonjour dans les
titres cette semaine l'ump choisi son
nouveau président c'est la fin ce week
end une longue campagne interne entre
nicolas sarkozy bruno le maire et hervé
mariton dernière ligne droite c'est le
rendez vous incontournable des mères la
mère tenait son congrès annuel cette
semaine porte de versailles autre
réforme des rythmes scolaires la bête
dotation et les nouvelles cartes de
france d'homère ont le blues et l'ont
fait savoir il y à 40 ans débutait les
débats sur la loi veil à cette occasion
un téléfilm revient sur le combat de
simone veil s'est le plus de l'hebdo et
à l'assemblée les députés ont voté une
proposition de résolution pour
réaffirmer le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse notre invité
cette semaine pour commenter toute cette
actualité christian jacob bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député ump de l'oise
le président de seine-et-marne de cdm de
députés a évidemment de cinéma de
président du groupe ump à l'assemblée
nationale vous connaissez le principe de
cette émission il ya un portrait qui a
réalisé ce portrait réalisé et bien par
les parlementaires eux mêmes qui vont
parler de vous propose de les écouter et
or vient juste après pour rediscuter le
calme des vieilles troupes ancrée dans
le terroir ça c'est christian jacob qui
a énormément de qualités et qui
véritablement est souvent méconnue mais
il est clair que c'est un excellent
président du groupe je dirais pas qu'il
est sectaire parce que je crois pas que
l'on puisse dire quand ces prises de
position se soient animés par le
sectarisme mais en revanche que défense
un peu un très intransigeante
des membres de son groupe et puis c'est
pas facile tous les jours d président du
groupe ump quand on sert toutes les
divisions qu'il y avait au sein du
groupe ump christian jacob pour moi
c'est la fidélité en politique ne
partageons pas les mêmes convictions
mais c'est quelqu'un que je respecte
parce que il est fidèle à jacques chirac
à qui il doit je crois une grande partie
de sa carrière humainement j'ai beaucoup
de respect pour lui pour cette raison je
voudrais revenir sur cette question de
fidélité vous avez été fidèle à jacques
chirac de tes fidèles également à jean
françois copé pour rester toujours
fidèles pour sa copie oui bien sûr les
liens d'amitié alors les relations avec
un autre jacques chirac et jean françois
copé car bien sûr garantie pour jacques
chirac à la fois une admiration énorme
très grand respect et puis effectivement
beaucoup d'amitié jean-françois s'éteint
c'est un ami de combat politique on a
nos relations qui étaient différentes
mais qui est aussi très amicale et qui
leur est bien évidemment ça fait
d'allaiter ça paye en politique aussi
oui on le sujet voilà on l'est on l'est
pas fidèle bon voilà on n'oublie pas
assez ses amis on passe
c'est la vie politique est difficile
elle est dure on donne des coups mais on
en encaisse
beaucoup votre phrase oui je ne suis pas
convaincu de sa part convaincu de sa en
revanche il faut se tenir sur quelques
quelques lignes et
les liens d'amitié moi je savais j'ai
conservé les amis de syndicalisme il ya
25 ans que j'ai quitté le syndicalisme
est conservée d'autres sur les sur les
bancs d'école je crois cette valeur de
l'amitié alors évidemment des semaines
commence par l'indiquent et le lundi le
président de la république tient ses
promesses
françois hollande avait promis de
revenir chaque année à florange en
moselle promesses tenues le chef de
l'état qui a rappelé ses prouesses à
l'égard du site symbolique malgré la
fermeture des hauts fourneaux je vous
propose d'écouter françois hollande
revient pendant discuter tout de suite
après tout les engagements ou des tenues
aussi les engagements en matière de
redressement les mecs des engagements en
matière d'investissement et les
engagements en matière de recherche prix
c'est ce que j'ai voulu démontrer et si
je viens chaque année c'est pour faire
la démonstration que non seulement la
parole est tenu et qu'on allait même
plus loin en masse tony dit le président
de la république moi je voudrais ainsi
alain petit peu plus loin comme l'a dit
le président de la république et aux
gandranges pour nicolas sarkozy et à
florange pour françois hollande ce sont
des symboles très fort pour le
quinquennat de ces deux présidents
tenue et non tenues et parce que quand
on entend françois hollande dire
promesse tenue il revient chaque année à
florange vont j'ai noté qu'il était
obligé de passer par une porte dérobée
parce qu'il semble que tous les salariés
et anciens salariés du site n'était pas
n'étaient pas convaincus du reclassement
donc bon ce qui relativise les choses
disons qu'il y aura au moins une
promesse de tenues c'est que chaque
année il fera un détour certes par une
porte dérobée mais il ira à florange
voies de communication oui
c'est aussi comme le symbole de ces
usines qui ont fermé que ce soit à
grandes robes à fleurs rouges pour les
hauts fourneaux ce cas de symbole très
fort des quinquennats oui vous avez bien
sûr l'industrie ne fonctionne plus
fonctionner de la même façon oui alors
ça c'est un autre sujet qu'on peut qu'on
peut ouvrir effectivement on a un
problème de
compétitivité de coût du travail est
d'une nécessité de réformes de structure
skill et symbolisé par nicolas nommé à
dix comme bien sûr ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que sur le coût du travail
qui est un sujet majeur en france on
peut pas le résoudre par un claquement
de doigts enfin on n'a pas une mesure
puis ça y est ça va être réglé il ya
besoin de temps il ya besoin d'action
pour diminuer ce coût du travail or le
reproche que l'on fait que je fais à
françois hollande à son gouvernement
c'est de n'avoir porté aucune aucune
réforme de structure qui vise à baisser
le coût du travail rien sur les
retraites rien sur le temps de travail
rien sur le financement de la protection
sociale sur ces sujets vous vers les
chantiers je n'ai rien aucune réforme
aucune nicolas sarkozy en apporter
peut-être pas suffisamment et on peut
lui faire ce reproche et moi je
l'accepté volontiers et j'en suis
solidaire puisque j'étais aussi
président du groupe parlementaire à ce
moment là donc je suis complaisance de
dire ça résiste aussi quelque part le
vôtre oui mais tout à fait bien ou bien
évidemment on l'assument collectivement
sur les retraites il fallait allonger la
durée de cotisation est passée de 60 ans
à 62 ans je pense que ça n'est pas assez
qu'il faut mettre l'âge légal à 65 ans
sur le financement de la protection
sociale on a essayé de le basculer sur
l'assiette de tva c'est à dire ce qui
permettait de baisser le coût du travail
stern arrêter de financer la protection
sociale uniquement sur le travail donc
ça permettait de redonner du salaire
aurait augmenté le salaire net et de
baisser le coût du travail pour les
entreprises mais on l'a voté trop tard
et donc on a un certain nombre de
reproches à suez simplement les réformes
de structure nicolas sarkozy les a fait
vraiment pas suffisamment peut-être trop
tard mais les engagés françois hollande
rien rien rien depuis deux ans alors
justement réformes de structure mardi à
l'assemblée nationale ce sont dessiner
les contours d'une nouvelle carte de
france
et c'est une carte de france à xiii
région vous allez la découvrir les
députés ont adopté la réforme
territoriale en seconde lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
un vote serré jeudi la commission mixte
paritaire qui réunit sept députés et
sénateurs ath a échoué le texte va donc
à nouveau être examiné par les sénateurs
et l'assemblée devrait ensuite adopté la
version définitive d'ici la fin de
l'année christian jacob on a envie de
dire tout ça pour ça est ce qu'il n'ya
pas de la perte de temps est ce qu'il ne
faut pas rationaliser le travail
parlementaire toutes ces navettes que
l'on voit de ce texte mais le fond du
problème c'est que encore une fois c'est
une opération de communication
aucune réforme de structure nous savions
nous avons aujourd'hui
4,4 strates de collectivités la commune
l'intercommunalité le conseil général le
conseil régional nous nous avions engagé
une réforme de structure de fonds qui
visait de ramener ces quatre strates à
trois strates c'est à dire en créant le
conseiller territorial
on a poussé on aboutissait à terme à la
fusion des deux collectivités région ont
été supprimés non mais attendez je
voudrais juste action ça prend trois ans
nous étions engagés sur cette réforme de
structure qui visait donc à fusionner
départements et régions on se retrouvait
donc avec trois strates aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce que 2,4
strates de collectivités on passe à
trois noms est-ce qu'on reste à quatre
noms on en crée une cinquième c'est à
dire que vous allez avoir la commune
l'intercommunalité le conseil général le
conseil régional et les métropoles donc
on baisse les dotations aux
collectivités et on en crée une de plus
ce qui fait donc les collectivités n'ont
plus de financement pour investir et
donc tout cet argent ne sert qu'à
financer du fonctionnement pour du
fonctionnement c'est une hérésie cette
réforme c'est n'importe quoi mais faire
et je réponds dans le sens de l'europe
de grandes régions privées mais le sujet
n'est pas là le sujet c'était dans le
sens du contribuable est ce que cette
réforme apporte quelque chose oui ou non
elle est catastrophique
il n'y aura pas d'économie parce qu'on
crée une strate de plus et en plus on
diminue les dotations doc ce qui veut
dire que les collectivités auront moins
de capacité d'investissement et aussi du
fonctionnement pour du fonds que on
n'est pas une usine à gaz c'est en plus
au delà de ça on n'a même pas défini les
compétences mais ça varie bien candidat
mais jusqu'à mais attendez moi c'est se
fiche du monde définir un essai de tous
les noms mais bien sûr mais définir un
périmètre de collectivités en disant ce
qu'on y fera on verra après l'important
c'est de créer une collectivité de plus
allons-y mais c'est vraiment le commun
du socialisme d'accord dans tout ce
qu'il a de plus permis mais il essaye
d'avancer quelque part aussi je peux
falloir leur défenseur mais je dis vous
propose que ce que dit manuel valls il
dit nous sommes dans le corps des
réformateurs vous vous êtes plutôt d'un
corps des conservateurs ceux qui ne
veulent rien faire bouger de rester figé
qu'est ce que vous dites mais je dis
qu'il ne fait aucune réforme c'est la
fuite en avant monsieur valse tant qu'il
s'agit d'être dans le verbe est très
courageux dans l'action il est
inexistant qu'est-ce qui fait comme
raifort y créer une collectivité de plus
vous croyez qu'on manque de
collectivités en france qu'on a besoin
d'en rajouter des strates avec toujours
un coût supplémentaire ces métropoles et
vont vivre de quoi de l'argent du
contribuable donc encore ni des taxes
supplémentaires encore des infos
supplémentaires et aucune capacité
d'investissement vous approchez vous
serez obligés d'augmenter les impôts
locaux j'essaye d'éviter de le faire
j'étais j'ai fait partie des villes de
plus de 10 mille habitants qui ont
baissé les impôts sous le précédent
mandat et je gêne et finalement j'ai un
objectif de tenir de ne pas augmenter
les impôts mais c'est effectivement
alain juppé est très clairement dit
devant la mf devant l'association des
maires de france je n'aurai pas de
france obligée d'augmenter en polonais
moi je vais essayer d'éviter de le faire
mais mais je n'en suis pas convaincu
puisque en baissant les dotations et en
créant un collectif d'une strate de plus
c'est vraiment n'importe quoi alors
avant ce repas ce mercredi dernière
ligne droite pour les candidats à la
présidence de l'ump
nicolas sarkozy bruno le maire hervé
mariton ils sont trois sur la dernière
ligne de départ trois hommes pour un
poste la présidence de l'ump tous ont
des propositions différentes on voit ça
avec elisa berthonneau mais il veut
reprendre le parti en main et tout
changé à l'ump grand favori nicolas
sarkozy a pourtant à peine précisé
pendant sa campagne ces projets pour
l'après élection changer de nom
supprimer les courants créer un grand
parti regroupant la droite et le centre
oui mais peu de détails supplémentaires
en meeting nicolas sarkozy parle de la
france presque comme si le candidat tu
es à la présidence de l'elysée et non à
celle de l'ump la grande formation
politique moderne que nous allons faire
émerger ne sera pas qu'une grande force
d'opposition elle sera une grande force
de proposition
d'imagination face aux grandes mutations
du monde à toutes les crises qu'elles
engendrent et a toutes les chances
qu'elle offre aux audacieux et vous
verrez mes chers amis qu'ensemble nous
allons réussir de grandes choses bruno
le maire lui a choisi une autre manière
de faire campagne devant des salles plus
petites le candidat défend sa doctrine
le renouveau des idées des élites des
pratiques mais contrairement à son rival
lui veut garder l'ump sans alliance avec
le centre je veux qu'on garde le nom de
l'ump c'est très important
c'est comme ça que les militants ump
vont trancher est-ce que le 29 novembre
gain de l'ump ce que je propose ou est
ce que l'ump disparaît c'est quand même
pas un choix anecdotique est-ce qu'on
assume ce que je veux un positionnement
de droite avec des idées de droite pro
l'ump ou est ce qu'au contraire on
essaie d'aller vers une fusion avec lui
dit le centre pour faire un grand
ensemble qui n'est pas très clair c'est
des choix absolument fondamentaux le
credo d'hervé mariton la transparence
dans la gestion du parti et pour se
démarquer de ses rivaux le candidat
outsider rappelle que lui n'a jamais été
rattrapé par les affaires qui minent
l'ump moi je vous dis les choses ou bien
très clair il faudra aller au bout
assurer une complète transparence et en
même temps ça n'est pas le seul sujet de
l'avenir l'ump j'ai aussi cette force
évidemment de dire que des trois
candidats je suis le seul des trois ne
pas avoir été en affaire rigby maillon
ça c'est une réalité concrète et une
fois qu'on a dit cela pour l'essentiel
on s'attache à l'avenir sur un point au
moins les trois candidats s'accordent
aucun ne s'est officiellement déclarée
comme candidat à la primaire pour 2010
est pour l'instant et cette élection à
la tête de l'ump c'est notre zoom de la
semaine
frédéric dabi bonjour vous êtes
directeur département d'opinion et
stratégie d'entreprise à l'ifop quel
regard vous portez sur cette campagne de
l'ump est ce une campagne honnête
contrairement à la dernière c'est une
campagne qui s'est passé qui s'est
plutôt bien passé qui a été marquée par
le retour de nicolas sarkozy sur la
scène politique par une campagne très
longue et très efficace de terrain de
bruno le maire parent hervé mariton qui
a réussi à imposer son thème de mariage
pour tous alors la seule fois où les
trois candidats ont été en somme c'était
lors du meeting du sens commun et puis
bon cette campagne restera aussi marqué
par ce qui s'est passé à bordeaux les
sifflets du alain juppé deux cent
soixante mille adhérents à peu près plus
ou moins qui sont qui vont devoir voter
ce week-end impossible pour vous de
faire des sondages mais tout à fait il
faut avoir l'honnêteté de dire qu'on ne
peut pas faire des sondages pour faire
un sondage il faut lui il faut il faut
il faut un ficher donc les sondages et
qui sont faits
par quelques instituts mais pas par
l'ifop sont faits auprès des
sympathisants pour pouvoir faire un
sondage efficace il faut avoir du
fichier des adhérents de l'ump ce n'est
pas possible les questions posées la
sonde est question de préférence auprès
des sympathisants de au cratère d'une
surprise christian jacob un point sur
ces les militants qui décident vous y
croyez vous
à quoi la surprise je sais pas ce que ça
dépend ce que moi
je sais que vous avez décidé de ne pas
donner votre choix de vote personnelles
mais quelque chose quand même quelqu'un
vous a surpris pas dans cette campagne à
des candidats non je trouve qu'on a eu
l'analyse de frédéric dabi parfaite
c'est à dire on a
effectivement une campagne qui s'est
bien passé d'abord au delà on peut
toujours y avoir quelques quelques
phrases un peu malheureux ici ou là mais
d'abord ça n'a pas émaner des combines
des candidats plus souvent leur
entourage que des candidats eux mêmes
ils ont parcouru la france chacun avec
leur tempérament leur conviction sur le
fond objectivement il n'y a pas de
grande différence c'est plus des
différences de personnalité et de
tempérament et d'expérience les
crevasses et bruno le maire est d'accord
comment oui oui c'est vrai qu'avec un
écran non vous ne bruno le maire parce
que la presse globalement dudit disons
le avais pas envie peut-être de revoir
nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui et donc il
ya eu les candidats qui se présente en
outsider on était plus beaucoup plus
portée médiatiquement que nicolas
sarkozy voilà hors de l'eau mais
reconnaît bien des médias c'est un peu
ce que vous dites peut apporter beaucoup
plus portée effectivement médiatiquement
mais mais c'est aussi révélateur de
quelque chose simplement
parce que par une envie de renouveau au
sein du parti c'est ce qu'on entend chez
les sympathisants les militants bruno le
maire on verra sur les militants
attendent en attendant samedi soir vous
savez moi je suis beaucoup plus prudent
que quelques que cela mais il ya eu
effectivement parce que personne au
départ on attendait plutôt peut-être
bruno le maire comme candidat c'est à
cette élection donc du coup il ya eu un
soutien assez large de la précision le
si on prend le nombre de papiers bond
par rapport à hervé mariton moi je pense
qu il ya vait mariton est sous-estimée
dans l'est dans les résultats que l'on
entend et je tiens je connais maintenant
et je sais gré à l'ifop ne pas rentrer
dans des sondages parce qu'effectivement
les sondages ne veulent rien dire dans
la mesure où on n'a pas un fichier on
n'a pas un corps électoral définit un
listing des très compliqué de faire un
sondage aimé couramment caricature hervé
mariton sur le mariage pour pour tous
moi je les comme collègue parlementaire
ça fait partie des piliers de
l'assemblée
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui est sur
tous les sujets qui étaient très pointu
techniquement
et très travailleur que l'on voit
beaucoup dans l'hémicycle et je pense
qu'il peut avoir une reconnaissance
peut-être plus important qu'on de avec
casque audio et comme un événement à
mario il ya quand même marqué cette
campagne ce sont les sifflets samedi
dernier à bordeaux sifflé contre alain
juppé dans son propre fief écouter
plus que jamais convaincu de la
nécessité d'un large rassemblement de la
droite et du centre
si nous voulons pas trop le parti
socialiste face à la montée du front
national
je répète le mp a été constitué sur la
base de l'union et du centre et je
continuerai à militer qu'on ce
rassemblement de nombreux crédits sont
frédéric dabi cette image elle a marqué
cette campagne a qui est venu
c'est vrai qu'elle a marqué c'est vrai
que c'est l'acte lourd de cette campagne
c'est vrai qu'elle préfigure le futur
affrontement sans doute des primaires
entre alain juppé et nicolas sarkozy et
c'est vrai que bono maire a plutôt bien
exploiter cette cet événement puisque
même si là c'est le seul qui a osé en
fait affronter directement nicolas
sarkozy il n'est jamais apparu comme le
diviseur et il a exploité cette campagne
cep cet événement en se disant le
rempart à la future guerre des chefs et
n'oublions pas ce que les sympathisants
je préviens des sympathisants ump
redoutent c'est la réactivation des
querelles de personnes ils ont connu ils
ont connu chirac-giscard ils ont connu
sarkozy dominique de villepin copé
fillon en 2012 qui ne veulent pas je
pense un affreux juppé semble logique
juppé sarkozy mais c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être le premier acte de ce qu'il
commencera peut-être dès le 30 novembre
c'est à dire cette course d'un an et
demi à la primaire ump je peux faire
coter ça peut être là aussi les gains
d'échelle sur les sifflets je pense
qu'il faut aussi relativiser les choses
à partir du moment où on dit dans la vie
publique qu'on va dans des dans des
salles publiques ma france à moi je
viens du syndicaliste cgt pendant 15 ans
17 ans un leader syndical des assemblées
chaude on se fait ce coup et c'est un
risque
mais bien entendu que ça fait pas
plaisir mais dans la vie il dit que
c'est dangereux mais dans la vie dans la
vie dans la vie politique et publique ça
nous est arrivé à tous c'est arrivé à
nicolas sarkozy c'est arrivé à certains
moments à jacques chirac tous les
leaders politiques connaissent là et
donc il faut qu'ils se nomment d'état
pour pouvoir affronter ça non il faut
tout simplement relativiser ramener les
vacances est-ce que ce que parce que
nicolas sarkozy au métier comme un bébé
mort ajoute un petit peu un homme
politique digne de ce nom n'a pas peur
de se confronter aux idées des autres
elle a été tout simplement encore une
fois la jupe est sifflée dans cette
salle à bordeaux non mais enfin moi je
vous dis tout tout un bon c'est toujours
regrettable mais en même temps
relativisons les shows un petit peu plus
loin parce que finalement celui qui est
visé la danse c'est françois bayrou
c'est cette alliance de françois bayrou
avec fruits sont sûrs ils défient
popularité mais ça veut dire 7
comprendre pourquoi fred avec des amis
c'est cette primaire est toute la
question maintenant on va se poser sur
la presse sur le lendemain de cette
élection c'est d'abord vous avez raison
c'est d'abord les contours de cette
primaire ump est ce que les électeurs
sont prises vont aller voter massivement
il ya aussi c'est une certaine obsession
de nicolas sarkozy sur françois bayrou
alors c'est vrai que françois bayrou a
appelé à voter pour françois hollande
mais il faut dire aussi qu'une majorité
des électeurs françois bayrou dieu de
premier tour ont voté pour nicolas
sarkozy au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle et la stratégie de jupes
et qu'on voit dans les premières
enquêtes très présidentiel bien sûr
elles ne veulent rien dire bien sûr on
est très loin de en fait les chiens
c'est que
alain juppé mort très largement sur
l'électorat bayrou 2012 ce qui permet
d'être pour l'instant le seul à pouvoir
contrer marine le pen au 1er mai c'est
le coq date de la gauche une possible
hausse n'est pas très sérieux de dire ça
le clivage gauche droite et je pense aux
puissants jacob me confirmant existe
quand même fortement en france que
j'existe françois bayrou il a sa place
dans une primaire
c'est à françois bayrou de nous dire
s'il se reconnaît dans les valeurs de
luxe est bien temps d'aimer c'est à lui
de nous le dire
françois bayrou a appelé à faire battre
nicolas sarkozy à faire élire françois
hollande s'il a changé d'avis qu'il le
dise mais qu'il le dise clairement
quand on l'a aussi sur ce que représente
françois bayroux moi je le vois
l'assemblée vont modem c'est un député
il ya 200 députés ump dont si françois
bayrou dit oui j'ai fait une erreur je
me suis trompé j'aurais dû soutenir
nicolas sarkozy et je me reconnais dans
les valeurs de l'ump on verra
laboratoire n'est pas vraiment attendre
qu'il le dise merci beaucoup frédéric
pouvoir éclairer sur cette élection à
l'ump
et cette semaine les maires de france
tenait leur congrès
le congrès des maires de france s'est
ouvert cette semaine sur fond de grogne
d'économies à trouver bien évidemment le
pré ministre est venu quand même faire
quelques annonces détails et réactions
venir sociaux
manuel valls attendu de pied ferme par
les maires de france et par le nouveau
président de leur association
françois baroin s'est montré très
offensif pour son premier discours
manuel valls se devait de répondre par
une annonce phare et c'est sur les
rythmes scolaires que le premier
ministre a voulu rassurer les élus nous
avons donc décidé que l'aide de l'état
au développement des activités
périscolaires sera pérennisée au delà de
l'année 2015 2016
autrement dit le fonds d'amorçage sera
désormais un fonds de soutien aux
communes soit une enveloppe annuelle de
400 millions d'euros le premier ministre
a aussi annoncé un renforcement du
soutien aux politiques locales de
logements dans les travées les avis sont
mitigés
des annonces on en a pas eu beaucoup en
fait on a eu juste la pérennisation de
la du fonds d'amorçage c'est tout on met
ça le savait plus ou moins puisque ça
avait été évoquée lors dès lors des
débats va tout à fait dans le bon sens
on c'est un projet qui était très
ambitieux il faut le prendre comme tel
l'impression que le premier ministre ne
comprenait pas les rôles et les missions
des mers comment ils vont évoluer par
rapport aux baisses des dotations je
crois qu'il le sait mais n'a pas voulu
le dire de façon très claire pour ses
premiers pas à la mf françois baroin
réclament une réunion d'urgence sur les
finances locales un appel entendu
manuel valls donne rendez vous au maire
début 2015 pour une nouvelle négociation
c'est vrai qu'on a senti les maires très
très en colère que surgit comme vous
aussi vous êtes un maire en colère oui
oui on est en colère parce que
je vous dis autant les économies elles
sont à faire partout et il n'est pas
choquant que les collectivités doivent
en faire bien évidemment mais ce qui se
passe là réduire les dotations et créer
des collectivités de plus ça c'est trop
vite et trop fort trop a dit alain juppé
le site est tout le temps mais c'est un
peu ce qui agite devant le congrès oui
enfin c'est surtout une réforme qui
ressemble à rien la réforme portée par
le gouvernement c'est surtout ça avec
l'invasion de dotation
oui on recrée anglais qu'est ce que ça
change pour vous les 11 milliards de
dotation au moins en tant que maire et
qui sont à peine d'aller faire avec
concrètement moi c'est une diminution de
ma capacité d'investissement et à partir
de là les conséquences et son direct sur
les kilomètres de voirie que je vais
faire en moins sur mon budget l'année
prochaine sur des recrutements qu aurait
pu être prévu on va essayer de
rationaliser c'est essentiellement sur
de l'investissement
que l'on va réduire les choses donc moi
je pense que il y à un effort à faire
dans les dents les collectivités sur le
statut de la fonction publique c'est une
vraie réforme de structure à porter
réduire le nombre de stratèges encore
une fois c'est pas en regroupant les
régions le sujet c'est de réduire le
nombre de strates de collectivités ce
que à chaque strate vous avez un coup un
exécutif vous avez un coût de
fonctionnement vous avez des
financements supplémentaires attribués
donc c'est autant qui ne va pas aller à
l'entreprise de bt la période du secteur
que le toit sur les bâtiments sur les
gros travaux que l'inconscient
actuelle on les arrête on les supprime
que ce qui se passe on décale on décale
souvent mais donc quand on les décale ça
veut dire concrètement les faits pendant
l'année est donc la conséquence directe
c'est que le carnet de commandes des
entreprises de btp va va diminuer c'est
à dire un carnet de commandes qui
étaient pleins
il ya de cela deux ans encore j'avais
pratiquement un an d'avancé de travail
ils sont passés à six mois on est plutôt
à 3 mois une pm qui a trois mois le
moindre incident le moindre impayés elle
s'effondre est la conséquence directe
c'est celle-là est l'autre thème qu'on a
abordé lors du congrès des maires de
france évidemment les rythmes scolaires
le point de friction une bonne c'est
exactement ça manuel valls a très
clairement annoncé que le fonds serait
pérennisée c'est un fonds d'amorçage il
avait un fonds pérenne qu'est ce que
vous en process que c'est une victoire
symbolique que vous obtenez la auprès de
nom le victoire symbolique c'était de
retirer cette réforme qui n'a pas de
sens c'est très fort envoyé dans une
ville comme la mienne à provins c'est
six points l'équivalent de six points
d'impôts ménage donc alors je vais pas
augmenter les impôts mais en revanche il
y à des dépenses que je faisais que je
ne ferai pas donc vous voyez ce que ça
représente 6 points d'impôts ménages et
finalement pour avoir quoi pour
augmenter le temps en études surveillées
pour augmenter le temps en garderie
qu'est ce que ça va apporter de plus aux
enfants
si ce n'est de se lever une journée de
plus par semaine de bonheur de tous le
matin mais qui sont des causes
économiques parce que vous vouliez
l'argent pour que ça puisse fonctionner
non moi je ne voulais pas de cette
réforme ils ont pas de la réforme
ensuite le financement c'est toujours de
l'impôt c'est le contribuable c'est le
même c'est la même poche qu'on la prenne
au niveau local au niveau national si la
même poche donc claque il y à une
dotation tant mieux mais mais je veux
dire c'est pas ça
l'intelligence que devait avoir ce
gouvernement et ce que devait faire
manuel valls en arrivant à matignon
s'était retiré cette réforme ça c'était
du bon sens c'est un maire il devait
bien bien mesurer l'intérêt pourquoi il
l'a pas fait selon mais parce que ce
gouvernement s'est enfermé dans cette
doctrine de dire voilà j'ai lancé une
réforme je vais je vais au bout mais
c'est n'importe quoi sous selle c'est
très rare d'avoir une réforme qui fasse
l'unanimité contre elle par tous c'est à
dire que les enseignants sont cons les
chefs d'établissement sont contre les
maires sont contre les parents d'élèves
issus tous les maires sont à 90% les
mères sans son compte ce qu'ils ont fait
il en fait contraints et forcés en
disant on va de toute façon est allé
financement on va le faire on le fait
avec de l'argent public pour apporter
quoi aux enfants qu'est ce qu'il y a
plus à rien a passé un autre thème où va
revenir à l'assemblée nationale qui
essaye aussi de se réformer un moins de
questions écrites ou une nuit blanche
les députés se penchent sur le règlement
de l'assemblée nationale c'est en tout
cas une résolution présentée par le
président de l'assemblée claude
bartolone a pour résumer il y aura des
collaborateurs ont un statut les séances
se termineront à une heure du matin
maximum et les normes de questions
écrites sera limitée par député qu'est
ce que vous pensez de ces réformes
christian jacob vous le président du
groupe ump stop à l'inflation tempête
dans un verre d'eau forme est pourquoi
on change pas grand chose d'abord limité
le nombre de questions moi je trouve ça
choquant
c'est le droit fondamental comme le
droit fondamental d'un d'amendements
c'était un droit d'un parlementaire lors
qu'ils aimeraient une inflation oui le
ballon est rond point de vue sur tout ce
que le gouvernement l'exécutif méprise
le parlement et c'est là que moi
j'attendais le président de l'assemblée
nationale qu'il oblige le gouvernement
conformément à notre constitution à être
responsable devant le parlement et à
répondre aux questions qui sont posées
par les députés ces questions
normalement il y avait une procédure qui
était celle d'urgence c'est à dire
lorsqu'un président de groupe signalait
une question devait avoir répondre les
quinze jours le gouvernement ne tient
plus compte et il fallait que le
président de notre assemblée rappel à
l'ordre ce gouvernement qui en plein
dérapage et ses ministres qu'ils
n'assument plus leurs responsabilités
peut-être qu'ils devraient faire un peu
moins de comme être un peu plus au
travail le ministre alors justement par
exemple sur les sur la question des
séances de nuit elles sont limitées
jusqu'à une heure du matin alors
symboliquement on ne verra plus les
députés travaillent à 3 heures du matin
mais derrière il y aussi une question
financière c'est 48 millions d'euros
d'économies oui dans certains cas mais
derrière il y aussi une question
financière 38 millions d'euros
d'économies ça va dans le bon sens mais
bien sûr bien sûr simplement je pense
aussi qu'il serait beaucoup plus simple
de ou - légiférer le nombre de textes
mais mais mais qui sait aussi
qu'on
peut dépasser le texte macron on nous
annonce
164 arctique mais c'est n'importe quoi
si monsieur macron envie de se lancer
dans la littérature qui fasse qu'il
écrive un roman c'est l'organisation du
travail une réforme non il ya aucune
réforme de structure et et un texte un
texte de 164 article c'est n'importe
quoi d'abord si monsieur macron avait
été d'une fois dans sa vie je pense
qu'il sera un peu plus raisonnable et
encore s'il a envie de se lancer dans
l'écriture qu'il fasse autre chose qui
peut-être qu'il a d'ailleurs des talents
d'écrivain on verra mais en tout cas il
n'a pas de talents de législateur c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire il porte une
réforme sans aucune concertation où on
va avoir des phrases pour ne rien dire
dons qui permettent à partir du moment
où on commence à voir l'attitude de
l'opposition à l'assemblée nationale
cette fois sur ce genre de texte on
ferait demain on va de transition
systématique on va on va attendre de
voir de voir le trc aussi on vous rend
un petit peu le miroir où le temps cette
fois est ce que vous faites de
l'opposition systématique sur la rd 164
ça dépend des textes ad pense qu'il y
aura dedans or je sais qu'un texte de
160 cathartique ça n'est pas un texte
ces deux-là procès de la littérature
pour ne rien dire pour essayer d'exister
pour occuper le temps comme monsieur
macron en mal de notoriété les très
soucieux de son image se dit avec 164
article ma foi j'ai durer un peu à
l'assemblée donc je vais avoir deux de
l'image donc on me verdure avec le
nouveau ministre
oui oui parce que je vous savez ces
premières réflexions sont entrés en
politique n'a pas été glorieuse et je
suis toujours très sceptique sur
l'arrivée des des personnalités qui
viennent de la société civile je pense
que non je pense que lorsqu'on avec vous
mais lorsque l'insee oui mais lorsque
l'on à l'honneur oui mais avant d'être
ministre
j'ai d'abord été des ventes et j'ai
d'abord été maire et ensuite je suis je
suis devenu ministre et je pense que ces
ministres qui n'ont aucune expérience de
terrain aucune expérience locale savent
pas ce que c'est que des attributions de
logements ils ne savent pas ce que c'est
que de mettre en place un plan local
d'urbanisme ils savent pas ce que c'est
que de gérer une crèche que de gérer une
halte garderie et n'a aucune action
mieux comme ça devenir ministre bah je
pense que ça s'est rarement couronnée
par la russie il ya quelques expériences
revenons sur le travail parlementaire
mardi prochain les députés vont se
prononcer sur la reconnaissance de
l'état palestinien cette résolution de
reconnaissance incite le gouvernement à
reconnaître l'état de palestine en vue
d'obtenir un règlement du conflit les
précisions avec ahmed tazir
c'est une assemblée il divise et qui va
voter la reconnaissance de l'état
palestinien
le texte invite le gouvernement à
reconnaître l'état de palestine en vue
d'obtenir un règlement définitif du
conflit à l'initiative de la démarche la
présidente de la commission des affaires
étrangères pour qui rien n'est pire que
le statu quo la situation sur le terrain
est d'abord extra
violente très tendu et c'est précisément
parce qu'il est un blocage complet des
négociations parce que la colonisation
continue au point de compromettre l'idée
même d'une solution à deux états qui
pourtant nous savons est admise par la
communauté internationale et par le
gouvernement israélien lui
comme étant la solution pour la terre ce
vote un élément déclencheur de paix
c'est l'avis du chef de file du groupe
socialiste
nous voulons par ce texte après que
d'autres pays l'effet provoqué un
sursaut pour la paix valoriser ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans les territoires
palestiniens valoriser ce qui se passe
en israël et les prises de paroles qui
disent ça ne peut pas continuer comme
cela à gauche le texte sera soutenu avec
enthousiasme par les écologistes et le
front de gauche des votes similaire
viennent d'avoir lieu au parlement
britannique au sénat irlandais et au
congrès des députés espagnol différence
en france l'opposition en grande partie
ne soutient pas la démarche les députés
ump oscille entre la non-participation
vote et le vote contre il n'appartient
pas au parlement français de reconnaître
un état quel qu'il soit c'est une
question qui est laissé à notre exécutif
dont il préside en hollande de prendre
sa traçabilité qu'il n'a plus qu'ils
apprennent même si je suis reste
favorable à la reconnaissance de l'état
palestinien
je trouve que l' équilibre n'est pas
trouvée dans la motion à lui dit on
laissera les députés voter comme bon
leur semble alors qu'au front national
gilbert collard votre à contrer marion
maréchal-le pen pour la question doit
faire l'objet d'un débat ce vendredi
d'un vote solennel mardi prochain qui
dit vote solennel dit scrutin public la
position du vote de chaque député sera
donc connu là christian jacob quelle
sera la consigne de vote
consigne globalement aujourd'hui on a 90
% des députés ump qui sont opposés à
cette à cette résolution pour pour
plusieurs raisons la première la
première raison c'est que la
reconnaissance d'un état ça relève de
l'exécutif est donc adopté ce type de
résolution c'est affaiblir la voix de la
france soit le président de la
république tient compte de la résolution
et à ce moment là sa voix est affaibli
puisqu'il a enfermé dans une position du
parlement soit il n'en tient pas compte
et à ce moment là cette résolution n'a
aucun aucun intérêt ces solutions
c'est là je sais pas ce qu'ils influent
c'est la traduction d'un président
faible avec une voie qui n'est pas
portée contrairement à tous ses
prédécesseurs du général de gaulle à
nicolas sarkozy en passant par françois
mitterrand qui ont souvent été en
initiative sur ce dossier mais qui l'ont
été en tant que chef de l'état là on a
un président de la république qui
n'existe pas et donc qui se dérobe sous
une résolution débattu en catimini temps
d un sujet comme celui là l'ump à 15
minutes de temps de parole à quoi ça
ressemble d'aller traiter cela un
vendredi matin de cette manière on est
dans clairement et ce conformément à nos
institutions dans la responsabilité
directe du président de la république
qui n'assume pas et donc c'est pour ça
que la sauce personnelle ou 2e 2e
deuxième élément de 2 deuxième point
nous sommes tous unanimement tous les
députés ump sans exception favorable à
la reconnaissance des 2ème et à la la
coexistence des deux états mais au terme
d'un processus de paix clairement abouti
il est clair que ce processus de paix
n'est pas abouti aujourd'hui c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous refusons cette
cette résolution donc voilà 90% des
députés sont opposés et alors nous
verrons mardi comment nous allons
procéder certains me disent moi je
refuse de la cautionner dont je n'irai
même pas voter parce que je ne cautionne
pas ce système
d'autres disent moi je veux vraiment
marqué mon désaccord et j'irai voter
contre voilà vous ferez vous allez on le
définit sa vision du groupe oui je vous
le dirai martiaux et mardi ça vous
engage aussi bien sûr bien évidemment
fallait simplement ayant des bagages
d'abord avec mes collègues
parlementaires je suis leur président et
c'est dans ce cadre là je prends ma
maison mais comme israël de toute façon
ce sera une opposition ce troisième
résolution nicolas sarkozy dit pam il
faut voter contre ils appellent les
parlementaires qui lui sont fidèles à
voter contre ça vous embête que le
président l'ancien président roh
semaines du démarrage non je pense que
si quelqu'un est légitime pour parler de
ce sujet c'est bien nicolas sarkozy
parce qu'il a été lui en initiative
contrairement à françois hollande est
lui ne s'est pas dérobé de ses
responsabilités sur une résolution
parlementaire elle va passer encore une
fois à l'assemblée nationale qui a
examiné cette semaine une autre
proposition de résolution c'est le plus
de l'hebdo qui est consacré aux 40 ans
de la loi veil
c'est l'une des avancées majeures des
droits des femmes il ya quarante ans la
loi veil était adoptée elle aboutissait
à libé g france 2 a diffusé cette
semaine un téléfilm qui retrace le
parcours le combat de simone pace à
massimo barbarie l'a vu pour vous ils
vous résume ce documentaire
sous les traits de simone veil
emmanuelle devos retrace le combat de
l'ancien ministre de la santé pour faire
adopter la loi celle qui lie à 40 ans a
légalisé l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse trois jours et deux nuits
d'une bataille acharnée à l'assemblée
nationale c'est l'argument et la
temporalité de cette fiction historique
intitulée la loi bien sûr madame le
ministre dans tous les cas si nous
perdons la gauche il n'y a pas le compte
et on rentre chez nous pour trouver les
solutions les paniques et c'est normal
les arcanes de cette maison mais j'ai
peur que c'est une d'acteurs
chignon tailleur gestuelle intonations
la ressemblance avec l'ancien ministre
est frappante la ressemblance avec notre
époque aussi si la légalisation de
l'avortement a profondément transformé
la société française un tel geste ou
s'impliquent morale éthique religion
libertés individuelles ou encore droits
des femmes ne pouvaient que déchaîné les
passions en 1974
quarante ans plus tard cette
retranscription historique parfaitement
documenté ne semble pas avoir pris une
ride la baisse de notre natalité nous
laisse présager la même dégradation
profonde dont la france a tant souffert
que dis-je dont elle a failli périr
le film a choisi de contourner la
personnalité de simone veil et son sens
politique pour se concentrer sur les
débats législatifs et sociétaux qui
précède sa loi un parti-pris justifier
chaque année en france plus de 200 mille
femmes ont recours à l'ivg et j'ai
cette semaine l'assemblée nationale
examinait une proposition de résolution
pour réaffirmer le droit fondamental à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
c'est un texte très symbolique et
quarante ans après la loi veil vous
l'avez co signée christian jacob est ce
que vous avez reçu comme toute une série
de vos collègues l'ump des mails d'anti
ivg ce lobbying puissant qui s'est
exprimé juste avant la signature de
cette résolution
à ma connaissance mais si j'en ai reçu
de poids était très attentif moi je
considère que c'est une formidable
avancée pour les femmes en revanche bon
est-ce qu'il fallait que le commémoré
par une résolution bon ça a quelque
chose ces compagnies de résolution
objectivement non objectivement non je
pense qu'on aurait pu le commémorer dit
différemment moi je suis très attaché à
la loi veil encore une fois je considère
que c'est une avancée formidable apport
pour les femmes maintenant on a eu le
sentiment que la gauche voulait
s'accaparer
7 c'est cette loi et c'est ça que j'ai
trouvé un peu désobligeant mais est ce
que ça apporte quelque chose de plus
est-ce que ça retire quelque chose à la
loi veil non c'est la raison pour
laquelle je l'essayé mais je pense qu'on
aurait pu faire différemment pour
commémorer le quarantième anniversaire
cette grande loi aujourd'hui on sait que
les femmes rencontrent encore des
difficultés pour avorter que le sujet
est encore tabou on voit avec toutes les
pressions lobbying ou que vous avez
reçue à ce que justement il fallait
célébrer ce que c'était pas cette
occasion nécessaire de célébrer à la loi
veil pour réaffirmer ce droit des femmes
non mais je pense qu'il était important
de 40 ans après 2 le de le faire ça ça
ne me choque pas mais de le faire par
une résolution ou un groupe politique
essaye de se l'accaparer bon
dans votre groupe politique ceux qui ont
voté contre ce qu'ils ont fait avec les
convictions qui sont les leurs qui sont
tout à fait respectable mais qui sont
aurait encore des prêtres afin de son
trait très minoritaires au sein de toi
toi ni kruger un mot sur l'addition mais
toutes les convictions sont respectables
simplement 80 je crois 95 du groupe
cette résolution christian jacob un mois
sur la famille le conseil d'état se
penche aujourd'hui sur la circulaire
taubira et qui accorde la nationalité
française aux enfants nés de gestation
par autrui à l'étranger
si le conseil d'état valide cette
circulaire mais quelle sera la réaction
de votre groupe de l'ump moi je suis
opposé à cette reconnaissance
parce que à partir du moment où on
reconnaît effectivement la nationalité
française ça veut dire que deux fêtes on
va vers une reconnaissance de la gt1 et
et je reste opposée à la marchandisation
du corps des femmes ensuite on va se
trouver dans une situation très
compliquée parce que vous le savez comme
moi tout le monde tous les couples
homosexuels n'ont pas tous la capacité
d'aller à l'étranger de trouver une mère
porteuse donc c'est donc c'est le début
de la gpa c'est pour ça que je reste
opposée je considère que cette
cette circulaire est illégale et
j'espère qu'elle sera mais elle ne
reconnaît pas la filiation cette
circulaire elle ne donne pas de livret
de famille c'est la nationalité de fait
en hervé on gère on rentre dans
l'engrenage c'est à dire comment vous
pouvez accepter la gpa et ne pas
reconnaître l'adoption après à partir du
moment porte ouverte la porte est
ouverte c'est ce que je sais ce que je
pense c'est pour ça que je suis battu
contre cette circulaire merci beaucoup
que sur jacob d'art participer à notre
mission par le maroc de remercier mario
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
bonne semaine à tous